so this is kind of a pretty
straightforward way of doing this
there's no problems with this at all
okay but there's another way of doing
this which is um unique to the fact that
these are quadratic identities okay
so just leave a bit of space for a
second or maybe do this on the site
that's what I'm going to do this okay I
want you to illustrate something for you
if you take a straight line he's a
straight line okay and I say all right I
have a straight line and it goes through
some points on this Cartesian plane okay
here's a question for you how many
points do you need to provide before you
know exactly what line I'm talking about
right
think about it let's say if like say
okay I goes through the origin because
the origin right do you know you can't
conclusively without a shadow of a doubt
what equation I have in my mind and has
no you don't right because I can draw an
infinite number of lines through the
origin so you don't know enough where
you just have one point right what if I
give you a second one like that now do
you know it without a shadow of the net
if I gave you those coordinates you used
two point four and you like look there
is only a single straight line that will
pass through both of those okay so I can
know conclusively two points that
defines alone all right now let's think
about this guy if I said to you now it's
not a straight line but I hope Rabb
Allah in my mind okay if I said I'm
gonna give you a place just Hiba me do
you know without a shadow of a doubt
what the quadratic is no you don't
you're further set right okay I'm gonna
add a second point let's say young do
you know conclusively without a shadow
of a doubt yes you submit your toy
because there's still an infinite number
of parabolas that pass through each of
these two points right now I add
one more point okay now we're locked in
there's only a single parabola you can
draw that will go through all three of
those points right okay there's only one
that will satisfy all of them okay and
you can keep doing this by the way this
process as my degree goes up I can
generalize it if I had a cubic how many
points would you guess you need right
okay so you get the idea right now by
the way this number of points it
corresponds to something that's already
in the equation that I wrote down right
namely two points corresponds to two
coefficients you see that okay
three points corresponds to by the way I
say corresponds to it's not the same the
coefficient in to put it not the same
thing right but they still correspond to
the fact that you need three numbers
three numbers will define the quadratic
okay so if what you're sitting at to
prove is this guy there's another way to
show that this is true but I can take
three points if I can find three points
on one side right any three points I
like and sure they're going to be equal
to the same value on the right hand side
then they must be exactly the same right
if a little bit like you're trying to
guess my parabola right and I say okay
you try and say oh is it gonna go
through here and I say yes and then you
try and guess it's going through here
and enter here if I say yes all three
times that means we must have the same
parabola there's only one possible
solution okay so this is kind of um
method one that we just did
which is just a straightforward
algebraic simplification
he's method 2 which is about
substitution okay so I want to pick
three points three points on the
parabola and three values of x that I'm
going to sub into here and I want to
expect the same thing on the left and
the right hand side okay now I can pick
any three points I like right you know
how I just applied the East three to you
you can see these two a nice because
they're rich but you can pick any three
like these three if we have the same
three on both sides then they have to be
the same travel so you might as well
pick values that are going to be
convenient to right I'll give you one
for free right I'm gonna test X equals
the zero right x equals zero is always a
really good option to do because it
simplifies out so many things okay so
let's have a look at this for this kind
of straight
what's the left-hand side equal to when
x equals zero and it's not rocket
science
okay I'm gonna go it's a proof right so
it's giving you zero times this plus 0
times this ok so that's 0 and 0 that's
what I get ok and that's the same thing
as the right hand side for x equals 0
it's true side everything to say that
okay so tick I have a value right that
was my first point that I tested so it's
a little bit like it's also I think
bouches right where you're trying to
guess the coordinates you like oh yeah
you've you've sucked my battleship from
one of them can you do it another two
times that you got coal fit okay
I provided you at this point to stall a
little bit at the time what do you think
might be another easy value of x to test
out how about x equals a X equals agar
now hi this is not the only value I can
test rightly the reason why I've chosen
a is the same reason I chose zero
because it will make this guy go away
see that so let's test and
equals hey so one is my left-hand side
become I'm going to have over on the
left-hand side on the left-hand fraction
rather a times a minus a or b minus a 2
T what's gonna happen to that plus a
outside of a minus B or a minus B okay
this is really good
I've got zero here Plus these a minus
B's cancel selected a so it works okay
three there with us happy yes you have
to write for surplus amen
that's why yeah I probably should I
probably should have said that here as
well the same the same kind of rule
applies to when I cancel but that's true
yeah well yes and no because you yeah
yeah yeah I see um again I'm kind of
mentioning that as a formality it's not
the focus of it but so that you know why
we can do this all right so you see what
I've done
yep suggestion the right-hand side like
to prove that now I got provided to me
the question they said what were the
words a and B are distinct they're not
equal to each other and norms ero that's
cool that's right okay now you gotta see
where I'm going right I'm gonna hunt
insects EKU's fate now I didn't have to
texas x equals me i could test I mean
there's no reason why based on method
one we should be able to test any value
of your life but we might as well test
easier so let's go ahead and test that
loss value
ah I'll show you in a second but let's
just say okay right now the question was
how do I find that um you know what
these are equal to if that's the x value
what's the Y value and things I already
have by substitute here right so you
don't have for instance if I have y
equals x squared plus 5x right and if I
put in an x value like say x equals zero
right I'll get something out I'll get
something out and there's something that
I get out is the Y value right so even
though then the never pays any Y here
but Y is kind of in time all right this
is a y and this is another why I want to
try to prove is that they're the same
line okay they just shown a different
point okay so what I would then conclude
is to say therefore it's true for X
equal zero x x.b I've got my three
values I've got my three points on the
parabola right therefore I can just say
I've proved it that this Plus this
BAM exactly
okay and exactly the same way they'd
find two straight lines right even if
they were written in different ways if I
put in two values and they both line up
it must be the same line what other line
could you be imagining right it has to
be identical now you might look through
this feel like ah it's a bit of an
awkward way of doing it especially when
this way was just fine it was just fine
okay as you'll see in the exercise when
you go through sometimes depending on
the form of what you can give it this is
a dramatically simple way or a more
elegant way of actually showing it
sometimes it's not obvious what algebra
you're gonna do there but you can always
test out it you can always test values
it might take longer in terms of writing
but in terms of thinking it's very
simple just pick three pick three easy
ones and then off you go